Багато гончарів було, і задимлення дуже велике було,
бо ми палимо тільки дровами.
Була пані, яка знаходилася в селі Білий Камінь,
і сказала всім гончарам:
«Щоб менше було задимлення,
йдіть в ліс, знайдіть поклади глини
щоб була вода, щоб ви могли
існувати собі, і будуйте хати,
і там собі робляйте глечики, і там жийте, проживайте,
і ніхто вас там нічого не буде чіпати і рухати».
І так, гончарі пішли, знайшли
поклади глини, знайшли поклади води.
І так помаленьку заснували одне від одного
таке маленьке село Гавареччина,
в якому знаходилося колись 74 гончарі.
Ну, і зараз осталося 5 гончарів.
Кераміка це тут засновано.
Гавареччина – засновник кераміки.
Так, от в руках я маю глину, яка складається
у нас з двох глинів: з пісної і масної.
Одна глина прямо у нас одразу місцева,
одразу от в лісах наших, і оця глина.
Ми привозимо її додому, закидаєм в ванни
за пропорціями вже дві разом,
розбиваємо міксером в такий ріденький стан,
щоб вона могла пройти через сито –
отцідитися від корінчиків, від камінчиків,
щоб була ідеально чистою.
Тоді вона вже підсихає, отака в'язка стає, як пластилін.
Вона вже є проціжена, ідеально чиста.
Її потрібно так само «заклісувати»
в однорідний стан, щоб вона стала однорідною.
Все у нас, як то кажуть, не механізовано,
все вручну і «вніжну», ногами.
Гаварецька кераміка ще славиться тим,
що ще стародавній спосіб випалювання.
Все вручну, ніяких, як то кажуть, ні хімій,
нічого ми такого не додаєм.
Все екологічно чисто, все природньо.
Дрова, глина, вода і все тому подібне.
Як наші діди-прадіди от тим займалися, так і ми.
В мене брат запропонував, щоб я допомагав йому,
бо самому дуже важко.
Ну, от так, по чуть-чуть, по чуть-чуть.
Брат так само
їздив на заробітки,
а в нас вже були гончарі,
не хотілося йому їздити,
як то кажуть, на когось працювати,
так само вирішив по чуть-чуть пробувати.
Тоже не виходило, потім почало виходити.
І так, залишився в селі, так і працює надалі.
Роботи коїться дуже багато.
Найважча робота оце лощення.
Там сидіти на гончарному крузі працювати легше.
Оця частина, вона вже блистить, і таким чином
ми отим каменем оце все
залощуємо: тут полощено, вершочок.
Трошки він цей виріб робиться,
як то кажуть, глазурований, воскований.
Насправді воно не є, це є лощення.
В мене там назберується певний об'єм виробів,
і я тоді закладаю в піч їх.
Піч у нас неподалік, так на горбочку знаходиться.
Цю піч я вже сам побудував, її тут не було.
Я вже трішки дещо позмінював,
бо зазвичай люди колись в давнину всі печі
ховали так як би більше в землі, десь в долинах.
Я трошки змінив, тому що там волого дуже в долині,
внизу десь, в якійсь ямці знаходиться волога.
Я нагорі спростив, бо під час випалу
не має бути зовсім вологи.
От є в нас піч.
От я заклав повністю цю кераміку, і тут глинами
так замурував, і лишаю досить великі такі отвори,
для того щоб я міг потім бачити,
коли та кераміка мені накалюється.
Під час випалу, вже саме в кінці, температура
сягає 950 до 1000 градусів – досить велика температура.
Повністю та кераміка має
почервоніти, повністю фактично.
Я бачу вже, що вже ті вироби всі вони червоні,
і цей весь дим, копоть впитується
в яскраво-червоні стінки цієї кераміки.
Ось такий природній процес випалювання.
Так воно то ремесло переходить з діда-прадіда.
Особисто я вже 10 років займаюсь цією керамікою.
Їздив я і по роботах всяких.
Вернувся я сюди назад, і з'явилося в мене бажання
навчитися, в першу чергу, цьому ремеслу.
Я приблизно вже вмів випалювати,
бо з дитинства я ріс біля того процесу, це все бачив.
І вирішив я самим процесом зайнятися.
Ми чотири роки майстер-клас з дітками проводимо,
приїзжають дітки, бо їм цікаво, надзвичайно цікаво дітям тут.
І так трошки відроджуємо заодно і наше село,
бо воно на межі занепаду.
Якщо у мене є якісь більші такі групки,
що я не можу собі сам ради дати,
я прошу наших місцевих гончарів, задіюємо
більшу кількість людей, і так з дітками працюємо.
Я їм спочатку загально показую майстер-класи,
як це все відбувається.
І тоді ми ділимо їх по групках.
Одним словом, хто має бажання
вазочку зробити, хто якусь тарілочку,
я кожну дитинку стараюся запитатися
і їй одночасно догодити.
Отак це все відбувається.